The 8.9 mile gap between the European and
African continent known as the Straight of
Gibraltar is home to multiple strange territories
and borders.
On the European side, there is a 2.6 square
mile British Overseas territory named Gibraltar.
This means that Britain shares a small land
border with Spain.
On the African side of the straight is the
Spanish city of Ceuta, separated completely
from the rest of Spain.
This city is an autonomous community within
Spain, essentially having similar rights as
the independent regions that make up Spain.
A little more than 100 miles down the African
coast is Melilla, another Spanish exclave
in northern Africa.
All this means that Spain shares significant
land borders with Morocco, and that in effect
only one country separates British soil from
African soil.
Two other European countries also have strange
border relations.
Conventional wisdom would say that the Netherlands
and France do not share a land border.
Belgium stands between the two countries,
however, on the other side of the world, the
two countries do share a border.
The Caribbean island of Saint Martin is split
between a French collectivity, Saint Martin,
and a Dutch constituent country, Sint Maarten,
meaning that you can walk from France to the
Netherlands without crossing through another
country.
Also part of France is French Guiana.
French Guiana has the exact same political
power as any other French department and region
despite being on the other side of the Atlantic
Ocean.
It has a comparable relationship as Hawaii
to the United States—geographically separated
but politically integrated.
This means that France shares a land border
with both Brazil and Suriname.
There are two daily flights from French Guiana
to Paris which make for one of the longest
domestic flights in the world.
These flights take off in France and land
in France, but take 9 hours and cross 4,401
miles.
Despite this, this is not the longest domestic
flight in the world.
The longest is also within France and goes
from Paris to the French overseas department
of Réunion, located in the Indian Ocean.
The flight is 5,809 miles long and takes just
over 11 hours.
And over to North America, it’s impossible
to walk or drive from New York to LA without
crossing over water.
The Saint Lawrence river connects the Great
Lakes to the Atlantic Ocean, then the Chicago
River connects to the Des Plaines River which
connects to the Illinois River which connects
to the Mississippi River which flows out into
the Gulf of Mexico.
It’s also impossible to go from the South
to the North of the US without crossing water.
Theres one creek in the Teton wilderness of
Wyoming that divides at a place called the
Parting of the Waters.
One side flows 3,488 miles to the Atlantic
while the other 1,353 to the Pacific.
This means that this is one of the few natural
waterways connecting the Atlantic to the Pacific.
Near those great lakes that make up part of
the water split is Middle Island, Canada,
the southernmost point in Canada.
A majority of US states—27—actually lie
fully or partially north of this point.
The closest point in Europe to the US is the
Dingle Peninsula in Ireland, only 2539 miles
away from Hamill, Maine.
The island of Ireland is politically divided
between the autonomous country of the Republic
of Ireland and the section of Great Britain,
called Northern Ireland.
Although, despite the name, the northernmost
part of the island of Ireland is not in Northern
Ireland; it’s Malin Head, part of the Republic
of Ireland.
Now to finish it off we’ll head up to Norway.
Norway's land stretches over Sweden and Finland
to actually shares a border with Russia.
On the other side of Eurasia, Russia also
shares a tiny 11 mile border with North Korea.
This means that only one country separates
the Nordic social democracy in Norway from
the communist dictatorship of North Korea.